in this lecture we're gonna focus on
drug synthesis so I can show you some
interesting chemistry involving
heterocycles we'll focus a lot on ring
closures and just some general chemistry
that is useful in synthesis that maybe
you haven't seen we'll start by looking
at the synthesis of doxepin this drug is
used to treat depression anxiety and
insomnia and it does so by inhibiting
the reuptake of neurotransmitters
briefly in the brain neurotransmitters
are released they do their job in the
nerve synapse and then they're taken
back up but in some people this process
they don't do their job long enough for
the reuptake in too quickly and so this
inhibits that reuptake and allows them
to do their job for longer which can
modulate the mood doxepin belongs to the
class of tricyclic antidepressants and
you could see the three rings in its
structure in the first step of our
synthesis sodium hydroxide deprotonates
phenol creating a phenoxide the
phenoxide does sn2 chemistry at this
primary bromide this sets the stage for
our ring closure in the first step shown
here we have sodium hydroxide doing a
simple ester hydrolysis and so we go
from the ester which has an abbreviated
structure cooc to h5 and we get to the
carboxylic acid now I think here they
need a protonation step to get to the
acid if it is truly the acid they are
using in the next step so I'm just gonna
add H+ and we'll say we've added a
workup in here so promoting the ring
closure from our carboxylic acid is kind
of challenging carboxylic acids are not
easily attacked at the carbonyl carbon
because of resonance stabilization so a
way to make them more activated is to
convert them into the triply Triplicane
hydride is a really hot electrophile so
even something that's not very
nucleophilic like a carboxylic acid can
attack it we get this whitter ion and we
could show a proton transfer now this is
assuming they did actually do this
reaction on the carboxylic acid and not
on the carboxylate
need to account for our proton do a
proton transfer then we can kick off our
leaving group the triplet leaving group
is a very good leaving group because it
has resonance stabilization and an
inductive effect from the very
electronegative cf3 group assuming we
still have our our proton around this
will be protonated we'll have a proton
transfer to activate the correct
carbonyl for the ring closure and then
we just simply get electrophilic
aromatic substitution similar to a
friedel-crafts isolation reaction so we
get our attack elimination of triplet
again and if we call this compound here
our target just losing one proton after
this step will give us that product next
we have endo medicine this is used to
treat fever pain inflammation and a few
other things it does so by inhibiting
the cyclooxygenase enzymes these are
commonly called Cox and there's Cox 1 &
2 and the Cox enzymes are involved in
prostaglandin synthesis which is
critical in the inflammation process
these are classified as non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs or NSAIDs and
I'm sure you've seen this abbreviation
before our synthesis begins with the
Fischer indole synthesis the starting
point of that is nucleophilic attack by
the terminal amine on one of these
carbonyl groups how are we going to
control regio selectivity here we have
two carbonyl groups well we have a
difference in reactivity in each of
these groups the ester is going to be
our least reactive group in this
molecule compared to the ketone we have
this these lone pairs on oxygen here and
they're tied up in resonance with the
carbonyl giving it extra stabilization
so we'll get attack at our ketone and
with the Fischer indole synthesis we'll
need to have acid added into this
equation here now the compound that they
show is not set up it doesn't look quite
right to do the Fischer indole synthesis
and this is because they're showing the
amine form we can
convert this to the enamine upon
treatment with acid will get protonation
of the nitrogen subsequent in amine
formation let's start the mechanism
below so you can kind of see how this
works the first step of this is a 3 3
sigmatropic shift where we get electrons
kind of moving in a circle sort of like
the diels-alder mechanism if you draw it
out that way so we get our aromatic ring
attacking the double bond shift of
electrons and cleavage of the nitrogen
nitrogen double bond
this gives us our best Amin that wants
to Riera my ties and so if we protonate
this nitrogen we can get realization
readily
now we have a nucleophilic amine and
this can close down on the amine that we
have after protonation to form an
iminium ion we will lose a molecule of
ammonia and get our double bond that way
and in a few steps we'll get to our
target compound moving on with our
synthesis we get cleavage of the ester
with NaOH probably followed by an acidic
workup to get our carboxylic acid back
and then we have this DCC coupling this
compound dye cyclohexyl carbo dye image
is used to activate acids to undergo
nucleophilic attack let's see how this
works the nitrogen atom of DCC gets
protonated immediately by the very
acidic carboxylic acid let's continue
the mechanism here below
now our carboxylate anion can attack at
carbon pushing the electrons up onto the
iminium nitrogen atom now we went from a
carboxylic acid which is not very
susceptible to nucleophilic attack to a
very activated compound in the next step
tert-butanol can attack and now this
when it undergoes attack we can show the
electrons coming up if we want to use
the abbreviation from the Clayton book
we can show the electrons coming back
down and then cleaving off this urea
portion with the assistance of zinc
probably coordinating that nitrogen
after a workup we get our tert-butyl
ester and urea this is a preferred
reagent in this case rather than using
maybe a Fischer esterification because
we don't run a really boil our indole
with acid we could probably get side
reactions going on
so DCC offers us a mild way to perform
this reaction now the reason that ester
was put on the molecule you see in the
end we actually want our carboxylic acid
back was to prevent a side reaction in
this next step so here we have the
nitrogen getting acyl aided by this acid
chloride now if we didn't protect our
carboxylic acid we could have our
carboxylic acid react with our acid
chloride in a side reaction and so we'd
get nucleophilic attack and probably
complex mixtures so we can put on that
protecting group and then remove it with
high heat so the tert-butyl ester is
susceptible to D protection at high
temperatures let's see how this works we
can show this cyclic transition state
for this process where we show the
carbonyl oxygen of the ester attacking a
proton this causes an alkene to form and
we get our carboxylic acid back by the
final electron movement if you will in
that circle so this gives us our acid
and a molecule of isobutylene
next up we have nella Dix ik acid this
is an antibiotic that is especially
effective against gram-negative bacteria
it inhibits bacterial growth and
reproduction by binding to their DNA so
the active metabolite that's produced
from this compound will bind strongly to
the DNA but reversibly it is a quinolone
antibiotics ring structure in our first
step we get a michael addition however
our Michael acceptor has a built in
leaving group so let's see how this
works we get nucleophilic attack of the
amine on this carbon here pushing the
electrons up through the carbonyl for a
resonance form and then let's draw this
down here we can show collapse of our
electrons and pushing out of the leaving
group
you
I left our Amin protonated and just if
we call this our target a simple
deprotonation will lead us to that a
ring closing step is an electrophilic
aromatic substitution reaction and this
activated pyridine is going to attack
having the amine there is helpful we
could even draw a resonance form that
uses the lone pair of the amine to show
how this is activating the ring because
of geometry we get attack at the three
position and electronics favored this
attack as well if you know in our
product we have an alcohol and this
attack and displacement this acyl
substitution reaction will actually give
us a carbonyl so once we close the ring
we will actually use a lone pair on
nitrogen and we can show how we get a
second double bond in the ring and that
causes us to form an alcohol instead the
next step is a straightforward cleavage
of the ester to the acid again there's
probably a workup step here to arrive at
the carboxylic acid then we have a
little bit of an interesting process
where we get the purity nitrogen Lily's
sterically hindered purity nitrogen and
I guess it's activated by the Oh H at
the four position as well we get that
attacking at ethyl iodide sn2 reaction
that gives us a charged species which
then is reacted with the base that's it
in the same pot and that deprotonates
the ring we can push electrons through
the ring satisfying the positive charge
on nitrogen and that gives us our
quinolone structure
Oh mappers all shown here is a proton
pump inhibitor it's used to treat
indigestion and it's a really
interesting process it actually goes
undetected through your system until it
finds its way to the parietal cells of
the stomach where the acidic environment
causes it to convert into an active form
and then it will inhibit the proton pump
in the stomach irreversibly reducing
acid this synthesis is really cool it
starts with pyridine and we do a
nucleophilic attack on pyridine by
activating with methyl lithium so we get
coordination of the lithium attack by
the methyl group and then elimination of
hydride similar to the chuchi bob and
reaction treatment with peroxide and
acetic acid forms RN oxide which you may
recall undergoes electrophilic aromatic
substitution quite readily at the four
position and so here we can show our
electron flow from the oxygen of the N
oxide to do that EAS reaction so our
intermedia is going to be this nitro
compound which undergoes displacement
when treated with methoxide and again
the n oxide resonance helps this process
to occur our methoxy compound is then
isolated on the methyl group at the two
position this reaction is a pretty cool
mechanism so let's go over it when an n
oxide is treated with acetic anhydride
it attacks and in a few steps we're
going to get the acyl group on the
oxygen of the n oxide the process of
reacting with acetic anhydride kicks off
acetate as a leaving group that acetate
molecule can come back and deep
protonate oh the way I have my double
bonds drawn in the ring I will need to
push all around the ring to show how we
satisfy the positive charge on nitrogen
and make this exocyclic double bond we
then get another 3 3 sigmatropic shift
so we get a TAC of the alkene at oxygen
this bond shifts to the other oxygen and
we get cleavage of the
and Oh bond giving our acetate directly
our next step is again a straightforward
ester cleavage with sodium hydroxide and
this affords an alcohol on our molecule
because of the connectivity of the ester
so the carboxylic acid is the group that
were not even showing here then
treatment with thionyl chloride gives
this chloride which is ready for the
second stage of the reaction well first
get NaOH deprotonating our thye all to
give this anion here which undergoes sn2
reaction we have t bab in here tetra
butyl ammonium bromide this is a charged
but hydrophobic reagent and what it does
is it helps with phase transfer and so
it transfers molecules from the aqueous
and organic phase here we have a mixture
of DCM and water and if you mix this up
in a separatory funnel you would see two
separate layers with the DCM on the
bottom so we're stirring this reaction
rapidly and trying to get things that
are soluble in the water layer into the
organic layer and so t bab is the
reagent that helps with this process the
final step of our synthesis is oxidation
of sulfur and this can be done with any
peroxyacid let's go ahead and show this
mechanism I like to begin with the
carbonyl because I know that this is
going to form the carbonyl oxygen will
form the new bond with the hydrogen so
I'm going to start my attack there and
then this oxygen that's being broken off
can attack sulfur while sulfur also acts
as a nucleophile and simultaneously
attacks it we can show this next arrow
kind of cleaving the bond here and this
becomes our new carbonyl and I guess the
way I've drawn this I kind of need to
extend this arrow here from the double
bond to make this whole cyclic structure
and this is the most arrows I think in
any undergraduate organic mechanism we
have the oxygen attacking and being
attacked and this cyclic kind of
transition state that allows for
formation of acetic acid and omeprazole
in our case